el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador cambia de opinión sobre la
guardia nacional pie el día de ayer
congreso una iniciativa de reforma legal
integral con el propósito de que la
guardia nacional pase a formar parte de
la secretaría de la defensa
la guardia fue creada en 2019 por amlo
como una fuerza civil que serviría de
apoyo en la policía federal de la que
decía era irremediablemente corrupta y
que era incapaz de luchar contra los
cárteles de la droga ahora hace énfasis
en que de los más de 110 mil miembros de
la guardia nacional más del 80% proceden
del ejército y la marina y con ello
justifica un cambio de dirección sin
embargo necesita hacer una reforma
constitucional en el legislativo donde
no tiene mayorías el anuncio fue en el
cuarto informe anual del gobierno y lo
que hacemos estará haciendo un cambio
positivo y su administración creó con
racionalidad con mística y con optimismo
que triunfará la cuarta transformación
de méxico y en lo personal me siento
bien y de buenas a pesar de las críticas
sobre la ingenuidad disparada en el país
también muerto 19 periodistas en prueba
del año y la violencia es que las
mujeres se ha incrementado en los
últimos cinco años según la agencia
nacional de estadísticas habló aseguró
que bajo su mando los delitos de fuero
federal se han reducido un 29 3 por
ciento el secuestro un 81 por ciento y
los robos un 23,4 por ciento en cuanto
al caso de ayotzinapa donde la comisión
de la verdad determinó que los 43
estudiantes de la normal desaparecidos
fueron asesinados por fuerzas estatales
dijo que es una prueba que muestra cómo
se combate la impunidad que méxico
recupere su prestigio en el mundo al
dejar de ser el principal violador de
derechos humanos pero el caso de 2014
sigue sin resolverse